this morning we have breaking news from
the Korean peninsula where South Korea
has scrambled jets in response to a
massive show of force by the north
according to reports North Korean war
planes flew nearly 200 flights near the
border in the last several hours
Elizabeth Palmer is following this from
Tokyo Elizabeth good morning
good morning
the South Korean Joint Chiefs of Staff
said that the North Korean planes were
detected in several areas close to the
Border over a period of about four hours
in the middle of the day
all week South Korea and the U.S have
been conducting their largest ever air
grills yesterday they decided to extend
them a decision North Korea has called a
dangerous and awful mistake the U.S
South Korean Alliance and its formidable
equipment have threatened and angered
North Korea's leader Kim Jong-un this
week he fired off barrages of the kind
of short-range ballistic missiles he's
used in record numbers this year just
last month he observed launches that
state media said simulated attacks on
South Korean targets today he turned air
power such as it is North Korea's Air
Force has hundreds of planes but they
are old mostly outdated Chinese and
Russian models still flying them within
a few miles of the contested border with
South Korea and firing artillery rounds
in the area ratcheted up the already
high tension a few more notches
the extended joint South Korean American
Air drills are now due to end tomorrow
and people in this region hope that will
de-escalate the situation but if the
recent pass is anything to go by it
won't last Nate
Elizabeth Palmer in Tokyo thank you